this video is sponsored by hong kong
impact third i've got one question for
you weebs
do you like you anime girls well good
cause hong kong pack third is a free to
play action rpg that can play on mobile
and pc with cute anime girls coming from
the same developers that you may know
from gentian impact right now in their
news update we've got a new battle suit
kiana has blossomed into a true valkyrie
and transformed into the hershey of
flame scion unlike other hershey she has
an aerial mode where she can attack and
even evade mid-air but not only that but
she also has a herschel mode where she
can draw out a fiery grey sword i mean
just look at this thing man this is
chef's kiss the new update also
introduces a new rogue-like game mode
elysium realm revolving around upgrading
your valkyries with a unique skill to
clear a number of stages and don't
forget the best thing about summer
that's right it's the swimsuit skins
baby check out all the summer events and
the new summer outfits and you can also
log in seven days to obtain a new outfit
and an event stigma if you want to give
hong kong impact to try then click the
link in the description to download the
game today and you can also redeem a
free gift code on screen for 30 crystals
2 888 asteroids and a hershey trial card
and with that said let's get on with the
video mom mom
listen to me okay
it's called anime it's not called
chinese cartoons it's never been called
chinese cartoons it's always been called
anime okay i don't watch chinese
cartoons
[Music]
japan are the modern kings of 2d
animation while disney may have
originally set the rules japan have
continued to pump out and tell amazing
stories in the medium of 2d animation
even if it seemed like for the longest
time the rest of the world decided that
3d was the way to go but they stuck to
their guns and i think a lot of us
gravitated towards japanese anime for
this exact reason now with anime
exploding in popularity worldwide it
feels like they have kind of a
stranglehold when it comes to 2d
animated tv series in the modern day so
with the decades of experience and
wealth of talent in the industry we
won't really have to pay attention to
what other places are doing
right
every minute
in time
i did not think i would find another
show that would eclipse odd taxi as my
biggest surprise of the year so when a
new chinese animation link click popped
up as the 21st highest rated show on mal
i was just like
what the [ __ ] is this i mean just look
at this poster we got two very pretty
boys that the girls are obviously gonna
ship together oh no wait there's a girl
as well let me guess it's gonna be some
cliche high school love triangle where
he likes her and she also kind of likes
him but also has the hots for this other
guy who doesn't like her at first but
then it turns out he actually does and
then none of them confess to each other
and then it gets dragged on for 100
chapters and then it turns out she's one
of their step sisters i don't know where
i'm going and it turns out
i was absolutely wrong link click
follows two guys
[Music]
[ __ ] man i'm not even the hongo josie
and now meant to be neither young hun
how god i hope i pronounced that
correctly two boys who can travel
through time
kinda the two of them run a photography
studio which acts as the core basis of
their time travel mechanics being able
to see all the events that happen 12
hours ahead from when the photo was
taken and this guy can possess any
person who took the photo shenzhou shirt
is the traveller and lu guang is the
guide leading him through the events of
the past making sure he doesn't stray
off the path too much that it affects
the events of the present together they
tackle different cases ranging from
corporate espionage to human trafficking
to cute woman doing gay things sometimes
you just come across a show that doesn't
need to do too much to hook you in
because the concept itself is such a
strong hook it's just so perfectly set
up to tell interesting stories full of
stakes and conflict and what immediately
draws you in about this show is that it
doesn't [ __ ] around setting the stage or
establishing the ground rules of what
they can do and how they do it they can
only enter each photo once they only
have a 12 hour time period to do
whatever it is they need to do and they
both agreed that no matter what happens
they won't act to change the events of
the past this sounds pretty simple on
paper except when shenzhou sure
possesses a person he doesn't just
inhabit them he feels what they feel
censors what they sense and even get his
host's memory along the way but he's
forced to stay on the predetermined
script luguan gives him because whatever
happened in the past has to happen again
no matter how he feels about the
situation he's in the host got unfairly
judged or mistreated well you better
just suck it up and take it with no
karma because
what
what do you think this is a [ __ ]
dharma video
[Laughter]
it's not
it's not a diamond video oh what was
that the host slept with someone in
those 12 hours well you better get ready
for a ride baby because there's only one
destination and its name is bone town
the stage is just so perfectly set up
for an absolutely wild ride and the show
immediately delivers on it link click
has one of the strongest first episodes
you can find in anime this year the show
just throws you straight into the deep
end just [ __ ] full-on no loot
penetration right in the ass and after
the first credits start rolling you know
the exact play here you understand
what's at stake you understand the ride
you're about to get on and you know what
this show is gonna be all about honestly
episode one tells you pretty much
everything you need to know about the
series you're either gonna be hooked or
you're not being completely straight
with you just watching the first episode
would probably do a better job at
telling you guys if this series is going
to be for you than some [ __ ] on the
internet ever could who spends far too
much time now watching literal chinese
cartoons
hey guys please stay time travel's not
exactly a new concept in tv movies or
even anime and it's so easy to fall into
the usual pitfalls in most time travel
stories it's about changing the present
for a better future or changing the past
to middle with the present and then you
always get the inevitable paradoxes or
plotters that everyone just has to
accept because
i don't know
time travel in it but here it's more
about accepting that the past shouldn't
be changed no matter how painful you
know the outcome's gonna be i think the
most genius element they added was
having xinjiang sure get the emotions of
the person he's coming into juxtaposed
with the passive observer his partner is
some of the moments he can find himself
in can be absolutely brutal and he has
to truly live it acknowledging that you
have to be merely an observer to some
people's most intimate and most
traumatic experiences knowing that the
result needs to be willingly acted out
might be even harder than being that
person living in that moment ignorant to
what's about to come next when link
click truly shines it's in its personal
stories it's not always about the big
traumatic events but it's in the small
details that give so many of these
stories heart growing up in the
southeast asian family for some reason
every problem according to my parents or
aunts or uncles was resolved with
[ __ ] food oh you're hungry you should
eat oh you're not hungry you should eat
oh you're not feeling well have you
tried eating hey are you eating well oh
what the sky is falling the sea is red
and the world is coming to an end you
should eat
why are you so fat so just seeing little
things like a worried mum phoning up to
ask if her daughter is eating well then
traveling all the way to her apartment
to bring her some home-cooked food just
so she can get through a bad day i was
just like oh no oh god give me a second
oh
hold on i gotta phone my mom and tell
her i've already eaten today now let's
talk about the production values of this
thing
[ __ ]
normally when i do my seasonal videos
it's immediately apparent when the show
just has that extra bit of effort that
extra bit of polish to make it stand out
from your generic shows around it and
link click has this in spades the
backgrounds are gorgeous the art style
honestly looks like some kind of
webcomic brought to life even more so
than some actual anime adaptations of
webcomics the oc by itself is already
pretty damn good but then it also has
four or five different insert songs
spread out during the big moments in the
show and that's how you know you need to
take this [ __ ] seriously because you
know shit's real when most anime get
even one insert song this might not be
better animated than the best that
japanese animation has to offer but it
beats the [ __ ] out of 90 of the seasonal
dribble that airs not to mention both
the opening and ending which is just oh
god they're just
so goddamn hard the ending is such an
absolute bop that even though pretty
much episode ends on a cliffhanger i
didn't immediately start the next
episode because you know what i still
got time then there's the opening which
all i'll say about this is as a man who
skips anime openings i never want to
skip this opening i mean just listen to
this look how [ __ ] cool this is just
look at this hand animation man [ __ ]
smoother than an average league of
legends player's brain hopefully you
think this sounds pretty hype because i
did so much so that i said on twitter
that this could possibly be an anime of
the year contender which was
wrong okay i might have got a bit
carried away but i was just so hyped to
find a gem that i hadn't seen anyone
talk about i think the weakest part of
the show actually is when it remembered
it had an ongoing murder mystery
plotline because every time it did i was
just like
get back to the side stories the show is
at its best when the two main leads are
just used as a vehicle to tell other
people's story and whenever it feels
pressured to refer back to the main plot
i don't feel like neither leeds got
enough development to be interesting
enough to carry it by themselves because
when it does it evolves into a more
standard time travel thriller plot line
which other shows have already done and
done better when the show hits though it
absolutely [ __ ] hits which is why
what we have right now is a damn solid
show is it an anime of the year
contender maybe if it had aired in 2020
when anime was going through much more
of a dry spell is it the 21st best anime
of all time
hell no but we do have a good foundation
having said that i think it's
unfortunate that even when i tried to
recommend it a lot of people didn't want
to give this a chance partly because
unfortunately this show is called a link
click so when a youtuber makes a post
about a show called link click and
people see the word link and click the
first reaction is where's the link and
what do i click on where's the hashtag
at but also solely because it was a
piece of media that came from china look
i'm just a guy who likes to keep it
simple i don't care where it comes from
i just like good [ __ ] and chinese
animation has been on the rise for a
while i've already made a video about
the esports extravaganza king's avatar
and i thought 2018's modal sushi was
excellent scissor 7 is the closest thing
we've gotten to chinese gintama but i
think link click is the first time
they've truly made a gateway show
something that i can easily recommend to
anyone has an interesting concept
immediately hooks you is so easily
bingeable and has great production
values it is genuinely one of the better
shows this year even in such a strong
year of anime and i'm just waiting for
the day i can finally start calling this
donghua to the masses instead of
clickbaiting this as chinese anime
because no one right now really knows
what the [ __ ] donghwa is if you're
finding this season a little slow which
it definitely is then this is something
you can easily binge to fill in the gap
now if you excuse me i have a phone call
i need to make
hi mom sorry i shouted at you earlier
today
yes i've already eaten
no mom it's not anime it's chinese
cartoons
[Music]
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you again to hongkai impact third
for sponsoring me today and also thank
you very much too alpha sigma basil
dysfunctional degenerate elephant ivito
jeff levardos manopla payne patchett
pony stark the walto and everyone else
my patreon for helping to support me for
today and making this video possible so
yeah right now it's coming to the end of
august and i'm actually going to be
traveling back to england in september
hopefully it's going gonna be the first
time i'm able to travel back to see
friends and family so i'm very excited
but i'm not sure how much time i'm gonna
have to work on videos in that time
period so if it is a quiet month for
uploads then you know why but you know
what the first thing i'm gonna do is i'm
going to get my ass straight to a
[ __ ] nando
and then say hello to my mum anyway
though that's it from me today i've been
giggling and i'll see you all next time